this right here is a simulation that was
created by Peter Cole encourage using
the Khan Academy computer science
scratch pad to better understand why we
divide by n minus 1 when we calculate an
unbiased sample variance when we are in
an unbiased way trying to estimate the
true population variance so what this
simulation does is at first it
constructs a population distribution a
random one and every time you go to it
it'll be a different population
distribution this one has a population
of 383 and then it calculates the
parameters for that population directly
from it the mean is ten point nine the
variance is twenty five point five and
then it uses that population and samples
from it and it does samples of size two
three four five all the way up to ten
and it keeps sampling from it calculates
the statistics for those samples so the
sample mean and the sample variance in
particular the biased sample variance
and it starts telling us some things
about us that gives us some intuition
and you can actually click on each of
these and zoom in to really be able to
study these graphs in detail so I've
already taken a screenshot of this and
put it on my my little doodle pad so we
can really delve into some of the math
and the intuition of what this is
actually showing us so here I took a
screenshot and you see for this case
right over here
the population was 529 population mean
was ten point six and down here in this
chart he plots the population mean right
here at ten point six right over there
and you see that the population variance
is at thirty six point eight and right
here he popped plots that right over
here 36 point eight so this first chart
on the bottom left tells us a couple of
interesting things and just to be clear
this is the biased this is the biased
sample variance that he's calculating
this is the biased biased sample
variance so he's calculating it that is
being calculated as for each of our data
points so starting with our first data
point in each of our samples going to
our nth data point in the sample you're
taking that data point subtract
acting out the sample mean squaring it
and then dividing the whole thing not by
n minus one but by lowercase n and this
tells us several interesting things the
first thing it shows us is that the
cases where we are significantly under
estimating the sample variance when
we're getting sample variance is close
to zero these are also the cases these
are also the cases or they just they're
disproportionately the cases where the
the means for those samples are way far
off from the true sample mean or you
could view that the other way around
the cases where the mean is way far off
from the sample mean it seems like
you're much more likely to underestimate
the sample variance in those situations
the other thing that might pop out at
you is the realization that the Pinker
dots are the ones for smaller sample
size while the bluer dots are the ones
of a larger sample size and you see here
these two little the two little I guess
the details so to speak of this hump
that these at these these ends you
disproportionately it's more of a
reddish color that most of the blueish
or the purplish dots are sir are focused
right in the middle right over here that
they are giving us a better estimates
there are some red ones here and that's
why it gives us that purplish color but
they're out here on these on these tails
it's almost purely some of these red
every now and then by happenstance you
get a little blue one but this is
disproportionately far more red which
really makes sense when you have a
smaller sample size you're more likely
to get a sample mean that is a bad
estimate of the population mean that's
far from the population mean and you're
more likely to significantly
underestimate the sample variance
now this next chart really gets to the
meat it really gets to the meat of the
issue because what it's telling us is
that for each of these sample sizes so
this right over here for sample size two
if we keep taking sample size two and we
keep calculating the by sample variances
and dividing that by the population
variance and finding the mean over all
of those you see that over many many
many trials many many samples of size
two that that by sample variance over
population variance
it's approaching half of the true
population variance when sample size is
three it's approaching two thirds sixty
six point six percent of the true
population variance when sample size is
four it's a pop it's approaching
three-fourths of the true population
variance and so we can come up with a
general theme that's happening when we
use the biased estimate when we use the
biased estimate we're not approaching
the population variance we're
approaching we're approaching n minus
one
let me write this down we're approaching
n minus one over N times the population
variance when n was to this approached
one half one half when n is three this
is two thirds when n is four this is
three fourths so this is giving us a
biased estimate so how would we unbias
well if we really want to get our best
estimate of the true population variance
not n minus one over N times the
population variance we would want to
multiply and reduce in a color I haven't
used yet we would want to multiply times
n over n minus one we would want to
multiply n over n minus one to get an
unbiased estimate here these cancel out
and you are left just with your left
just left with your population variance
that's what we want to estimate and over
here over here you are left with our
unbiased estimate our unbiased estimate
of population variance or unbiased
sample variance which is equal to and
this is what we see we saw on last
several videos what you see in
statistics books and sometimes it's
confusing why hopefully Peters
simulation gives you a good idea of why
or it at least convinces you that it is
the case so you would want to divide by
n minus one